[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday
good morning John it's Wednesday good
morning John it's Wednesday
morning John it's Wednesday good morning
John it's Wednesday good morning John
it's Wednesday good morning John it's
Wednesday
John it's Wednesday good morning John
it's Wednesday good morning John it's
Wednesday good morning good morning good
morning John morning John good morning
John it's Wednesday good morning John
it's Wednesday good morning John it's
Wednesday good good good good morning
into Wednesday good good morning into
Wednesday good morning John good morning
John
[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday June
27th well I don't know if it was all
that dancing but there's something going
on in my pants what the heck it's like
oh it's spam well thank God there's not
any more spam in my pants the forum
should be free of the evil scum-sucking
spammers think I've deleted all of the
extremely gross posts if you see
anything else let me know you can email
us or just get us in the comments or in
the forum we're always around Thanks to
everyone who reported the initial
bombardment and happy birthday to cassia
that's all John I'll see you tomorrow